This question is sort of a big deal, it's where the
final project begins. And so work you do in this question
may wind up contributing to what you submit for your final
project submission at the end of the class. Since your final
project is the design of an app, the first step is
to answer the question, what app are you going to build?
And at this point I should mention it's okay to not
be thinking of personas and use cases and high level flows here.
This is where you decide on the project that is going
to excite you and keep you motivated, without that excitement probably
won't even build anything at all. So it's really important that
we start with what app do you want to build and here
we're really just talking about maybe a two to three sentence
explanation. Any more detail than that and you probably want to have
an idea of who your users are and what this app
is going to do at a high level. Keep in mind that
though you are going to be coming back to
this final project throughout the class you can always
change your idea. So don't feel like whatever you
do here you have to be too committed to.